LAST 16 DAYS THAT THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS TEAM KNOW THEY HAVE TO
ANSWER, WILL LIKELY HAVE TO
ANSWER IN THE DAYS AHEAD AND MAY
BE ANSWERING TODAY, GUYS.
>> THERE ARE MANY AUDIENCES FOR
THIS ADDRESS FROM THE PRESIDENT
TODAY, DOMESTIC AND FOREIGN.
PHIL MATTINGLY, THANKS SO MUCH.
>>> WE'RE LEARNING DETAILS OF A
SECRET AGREEMENT, STUNNING
DETAILS, BETWEEN THE TALIBAN AND
THE U.S. MILITARY.
IT WAS PUT INTO PLACE TO HELP
AMERICANS REACH THE GATES OF
KABUL'S AIRPORT IN THE FINAL
DAYS OF THE EVACUATION MISSION.
>> CNN'S BARBARA STARR IS AT THE
PENTAGON.
BARBARA, TELL US ABOUT YOUR NEW
REPORTING.
>> Reporter: HELLO TO BOTH OF
YOU.
LOOK, WE ALL KNEW BECAUSE THE
MILITARY TALKED ABOUT IT THAT
THEY HAD WHAT THEY CALL A
PRAGMATIC RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
TALIBAN, THAT THEY WERE ON THE
PHONE WITH THEM MULTIPLE TIMES A
DAY, THAT THEY WERE
COORDINATING, IF YOU WILL,
DECONFLICTING, MAKING SURE THERE
WAS NOTHING THAT COULD BE
MISCONSTRUED.
SO THAT EXISTED.
BUT WHAT WE ARE LEARNING TODAY
IS MULTIPLE DEFENSE OFFICIALS
TELL CNN IT WENT MUCH DEEPER.
THERE WAS, IN FACT, A SECRET
ARRANGEMENT WITH THE TALIBAN FOR
THEM TO GO TO MUSTER POINTS
OUTSIDE THE AIRPORT WHERE
AMERICANS WOULD HAVE BEEN TOLD
TO GATHER WITH THEIR DOCUMENTS
TO GET INTO THE AIRPORT.
THIS WENT ON SEVERAL TIMES A DAY
AND FOR SEVERAL DAYS.
THE TALIBAN WOULD GATHER UP THE
AMERICANS AT THESE PREDETERMINED
MUSTER POINTS AND HELP THEM GET
TO THE GATES OF THE AIRPORT
WHERE U.S. TROOPS WERE WAITING
TO GUIDE THEM IN.
WE HADN'T HAD A COMPLETE
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW DEEP ALL OF
THIS WENT.
NOW, WE SHOULD SAY, OF COURSE,
THERE ARE MANY REPORTS OF
AMERICANS NOT BEING ABLE TO GET
PAST THE REGULAR TALIBAN CHECK
POINTS WITH THEIR PAPERWORK
BEING TURNED AWAY.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THE
ADMINISTRATION SAYS IT GOT ABOUT
6,000 AMERICANS OUT, 100, 200
MAYBE LEFT THAT WANT TO LEAVE
THAT THEY WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
DIPLOMATICALLY TO GET OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
AT THE SAME TIME ANOTHER CHAIN
OF EVENTS WE HAVE LEARNED ABOUT.
U.S. SPECIAL OPERATIONS FORCES
WERE MANY TIMES ON THE PHONE
WITH AMERICANS TRYING TO
NAVIGATE AROUND THE AIRPORT AND
BASICALLY VECTORING THEM IN,
SAYING, WHERE ARE YOU, WALK
HERE, WALK THERE, GUIDING THEM
STEP BY STEP TO GET TO THOSE
ALL-IMPORTANT GATES WHERE THEY
COULD BE LET INTO THE AIRPORT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THE
CALCULATION ACCORDING TO THE
PENTAGON IS THAT MAYBE HUNDREDS
OF AMERICANS GOT OUT THROUGH
BOTH THESE CHANNELS.
VICTOR, ALISYN.
>> WOW.
WOW.
>> REMARKABLE REPORTING,
BARBARA.
>> BARBARA STARR THERE AT THE
PENTAGON.
THANK YOU.
>>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ALSO SAYS DIPLOMATIC EFFORTS IN
THE REGION WILL CONTINUE.
WE HEARD THAT FROM THE SECRETARY
OF STATE.
AS THE MILITARY MISSION ENDS,
THE DIPLOMATIC MISSION BEGINS.
THAT'S GOING TO DOHA, QATAR.
>> CNN'S SAM KILEY IS THERE.
SAM, WHAT HAPPENS NOW IN
AFGHANISTAN?
>> Reporter: WELL, CERTAINLY
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
QATARIS, AND THEY ARGUABLY HAVE
THE BEST INSIGHTS INTO THE
TALIBAN HAVING HOSTED THEM
THROUGHOUT THE PERIOD OF THE
PEACE TALKS WITH THE UNITED
STATES THAT WERE SUCCESSFUL IN
SOME REGARDS AND UNSUCCESSFUL
INTRA AFGHAN PEACE TALKS, THEY
HAVE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND
REGULARLY MEETING WITH THE
AFGHAN TALIBAN AND DEMANDING OF
THEM THAT THEY MAKE GOOD ON THE
PROMISES FOR AN INCLUSIVE
GOVERNMENT, FOR RESPECT FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS, AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THAT ANY
KIND OF FUTURE TRADE AND AID
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY
WILL BE DEPENDENT ON THAT.
NOW, FROM THE AMERICAN POINT,
PERSPECTIVE, THIS SPEAKS
DIRECTLY TO THE 100 OR SO
AMERICANS WHO STILL WANT TO GET
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN.
IN ALL PROBABILITY I THINK GIVEN
THE REPORTING BARBARA HAS BEEN
DOING ABOUT TALIBAN ESCORTS THEY
WILL BE SAFELY ESCORTED OUT OF
THE COUNTRY, EITHER OVER LAND OR
VIA THE AIRPORT.
ON TOP OF THAT, THE TALIBAN
SAYING TO THEIR OWN PEOPLE, YOU
HAVE TO RESPECT OTHER AFGHANS,
SAYING TO THEIR SPECIAL FORCES
AT THE AIRFIELD, STOP OPPRESSING
PEOPLE, DO NOT OPPRESS PEOPLE,
YOU HAVE TO BEHAVE IN AN
INCLUSIVE PAN-AFGHAN KIND OF
WAY.
SO MAKING ALL OF THE RIGHT
SIGNALS, BUT AT THE SAME TIME --
AND THIS IS THE KEY ISSUE --
MANY OF THEIR RANK AND FILE HAVE
BEEN PROGRAMMED, BRAIN WASHED
EFFECTIVELY WITH AN EXTREMELY
LIMITED AND PRIMITIVE FORM OF
ISLAM THAT STRETCHES MUCH CLOSER
TO SOME OF THE TEACHING OF
ISLAMIC STATE K, IS-K, WHICH IS,
OF COURSE, THE GREATEST THREAT
NOW IN THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE TO
THE SUCCESSFUL TALIBAN RULE.
THEY EFFECTIVELY NOW HAVE TO
FIGHT AN INSURGENCY AGAINST
ISIS-K, AND THEY ARE AWARE THAT
THEIR OWN MEMBERSHIP HAS BEEN
PENETRATED LITERALLY BY MEMBERS
OF THAT MOVEMENT BUT ALSO
IDEOLOGICALLY THERE WILL BE SOME
CROSSOVER.
THAT IS GOING TO BE VERY
PROBLEMATIC FOR THEM IN THE
FUTURE.
ALISYN, VICTOR.
>> SAM, WE'RE ABOUT 30 MINUTES
OUT FROM THE PRESIDENT'S ADDRESS
ON THE END OF THE WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN.
HE, NO DOUBT, WILL ADDRESS THOSE
WHO STILL WANT TO GET OUT OF THE
COUNTRY WHO DID NOT GET ON ONE
OF THESE EVACUATION FLIGHTS.
SO WHAT ABOUT THOSE CIVILIANS
NOW?
WHAT ARE THEIR OPTIONS?
>> Reporter: THEIR OPTIONS I
THINK ARE TO -- THIS WILL BE
HANDLED FOR THEM BY, I IMAGINE,
THE AMERICAN DIPLOMATIC
STRUCTURES THAT STILL HAVE VERY
CLOSE LIAISON WITH THE TALIBAN,
THE AMERICAN EMBASSY HAS NOW
MOVED FROM AFGHANISTAN TO QATAR,
HERE, SO THEY CAN WORK DIRECTLY
AND VIA THE QATARIS TO SAY TO
AMERICAN CITIZENS, DON'T WORRY,
WE WILL FIGURE IT, WE WILL
NEGOTIATE IT WITH THE TALIBAN.
I THINK IN ALL PROBABLE, BASED
ON THE PREVIOUS BEHAVIOR OF THE
TALIBAN DURING THIS WHOLE
PROCESS OF EVACUATION, THAT
SHOULDN'T POSE TOO MUCH OF A
PROBLEM.
THAT IS THE IMMEDIATE ISSUE.
THEN YOU HAVE THE OTHER ISSUE OF
THE MANY, PERHAPS TENS OF
THOUSANDS OR MORE AFGHANS WHO
WANT TO GET OUT WHO WORKED WITH
THE COALITION.
THAT IS GOING TO BE TRICKIER.
>> SAM KILEY, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALL OF THE REPORTING.
>>> LET'S GET ANALYSIS NOW FROM
RETIRED ARMY BRIGADIER GENERAL
PETER ZWACK, A WILSON CENTER
GLOBAL FELLOW AT KEENAN
INSTITUTE.
AS A VETERAN YOURSELF, WHAT DO
YOU WANT TO HEAR PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAY TODAY TO MARK THIS IMPORTANT
DAY?
>> THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
AND IT IS GREAT TO SEE MY OLD
FRIEND, KIM DOZIER, ONLINE WITH
ME HERE.
I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT NEEDS
TO CONTINUE TO SAY IT AS HE SEES
IT.
WE HAVE JUST BEEN THROUGH AN
EXTRAORDINARILY ROUGH CHAPTER
WHICH CLOSED WITH THE -- WITH US
DEPARTING KABUL AIRFIELD AFTER
20 YEARS.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT THE TRAGIC
SYMMETRY OF 9/11 AND NOW WE'RE
JUST A FEW DAYS AWAY.
THE PRESIDENT, WE'RE RUING THE
LOSS OF OUR BRAVE SERVICE
MEMBERS AND INNOCENT AFGHANS,
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT JUST
HAPPENED WITH THE U.S. MILITARY
AND FRIENDS, THEY JUST PULLED
OFF WITH A CLEAR MISSION
STATEMENT AND THEN THEY COULD
PLAN AGAINST IT.
IT IS THE BEST BIG PICTURE STILL
EXECUTING ORGANIZATION IN THE
WORLD, AND THEY PULLED OFF AN
EVACUATION FOR THE AGENTS.
I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE
WORSE.
I WAS MORTALLY WORRIED THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO TRY TO TAKE DOWN A
JET LINER.
THEY DID GET IN AND BLOW A
SUICIDE BOMBER UP ON OUR
PERIMETER AND KILLED A BUNCH OF
US, BUT IT COULD HAVE BEEN MUCH
WORSE.
I COULD SAY MUCH MORE.
I THINK YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THAT
AND THEN WE'VE GOT TO BUILD ON
THE FUTURE BECAUSE WE'RE IN A
NEW CHAPTER WITH AFGHANISTAN,
WITH THE OTHER AND THERE SEEMS
TO BE SOME DIALOGUE WITH THE
TALIBAN.
>> KIM, I SAID THIS WITH PHIL
JUST A COUPLE OF MOMENTS AGO,
THAT THERE ARE MANY AUDIENCES
FOR THIS ADDRESS, A DOMESTIC
AUDIENCE, A FOREIGN POLICY
ELEMENT AS WELL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT THE
PRESIDENT NEEDS TO ADDRESS IN 30
MINUTES FROM NOW?
>> THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO
EXPLAIN HOW HE'S GOING TO MAKE
HIS WORD STICK.
SO FAR IN THE RUN-UP TO THE
DEPARTURE OF ALL U.S. TROOPS, I
WAS ONE OF MANY DIFFERENT
JOURNALISTS, VOLUNTEERS IN TOUCH
WITH AMERICANS WHO WEREN'T
PERMITTED TO GO THROUGH THE
GATES TO THE AIRPORT AND ARE
STILL STUCK IN KABUL.
IN THE PAST 24 HOURS I HAVE BEEN
AWARE OF AT LEAST TWO CONVOYS
THAT HAVE GONE OVER LAND AND
BEEN TURNED BACK AT THE BORDER,
AND THE TALIBAN GOT ON THE BUSES
AND FORCED THOSE PEOPLE TO GO
BACK TO KABUL.
SO THE TALIBAN IS NOT HONORING
ITS PROMISE TO THE UNITED STATES
TO LET PEOPLE WHO WANT TO LEAVE
LEAVE.
THEY'RE NOT HONORING THE U.N.
RESOLUTION THAT WAS PASSED TO
ALLOW THE FREE PASSAGE OF
AFGHANS AND FOREIGN PASSPORT
HOLDERS.
THESE COUNTRIES SURROUNDING
AFGHANISTAN, THEY'RE SAYING IF
YOU DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT
PAPERWORK WE'RE NOT LETTING YOU
IN.
THIS IS A HUGE CRISIS IN THE
MAKING.
>> GENERAL, WHAT ABOUT THAT?
WHAT ABOUT THAT?
WHAT LEVERAGE DOES THE U.S.
TODAY HAVE WITH THE TALIBAN?
BECAUSE THE TALIBAN SAYS THAT
THEY WANT GOOD DIPLOMATIC
RELATIONS, BUT REALLY WHAT DO
THEY -- WHY DO THEY NEED IT?
AREN'T THE TALIBAN STILL
WELL-FUNDED BUY OUT SIDE
INVESTORS FROM SAUDI ARABIA OR
IRAN OR WHEREVER AND THEY HAVE
THE OPIUM TRADE?
I MEAN DO THEY NEED GOOD
DIPLOMATIC RELATIONS OR NOT?
>> I THINK THAT THE TALIBAN,
WHILE SHOWING, IF YOU WILL,
EXHIBITING THAT FIERCE
INDEPENDENCE, THEY HAVE A LOT OF
LOOMING ISSUES.
WE SAW THAT WITH ISIS KHORASON.
THEY HAVE EVEN INHERITED A
BUREAUCRACY.
WE WERE FOES IN OUR DAY, BUT
THEY HAVE SHOWN AS THE REGION,
THE TRIBES, A PRAGMATIC SHIFTING
OF LOYALTIES AND ALLEGIANCES
THAT MAY BE PART OF THIS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THERE ARE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT IN
AFGHANISTAN, IF WE GO IN AND WE
START TO BE REALLY AGGRESSIVE
MILITARILY, ESPECIALLY IF THE
TALIBAN HAS NOT CROSSED THE
LINE, WE WILL PUT ANY HOPE OF
GETTING THEM OUT AND OTHERS AND
LOSE, IF YOU WILL.
EVEN A TENDRIL WITH THE TALIBAN
IN THE COUNTERTERROR CHALLENGE
AND -- SO THEY'VE GOT A LOT OF
ISSUES TO BALANCE INCLUDING THE
EXTREMISM IN THEIR RANKS AND A
HOST OF OTHER COUNTRIES THAT
ARE, YOU KNOW, ALMOST